The resistance room testifies the war and the efforts of the Albanian people after
Skanderbeg's death. At this time Lek Du Kajini was the military leader who for 11 years in a
row withstand the attacks of the Ottoman army. The falling of the Škodra fortress in 1479
marks also the Albanian invasion which was accompanied by many murdering and
destructions across the country. Around 200,000 Albanians who could not endure the Ottoman
violence were forced to immigrate to South Italy, the Arboresh, where they have preserved the
language, culture and Albanian tradition. Through the exhibited documents in the glass cases of
this room is testified that Skanderbeg was not only a military strategist but also a politician
and diplomat of the time. He had diplomatic relations with European countries like France,
Germany, Austria, Spain, Italy, Greece, etc.
Janos Unjadi a Hungarian hero and Alfons V, the king of Naples were the two best allies of
Skanderbeg in the anti-Ottoman war. Also, here we have recognitions of Skanderbeg from other
personalities of the same time. There have been over 1,000 different books written about Skanderbeg
in 73 countries across the world in 25 languages. The map across shows the countries where
publications about Skanderbeg are found. The first publication about Skanderbeg refers from
the years 1508 to 1510 to History of Skanderbeg by the author Marin Barleti in Latin.
Gjergjari Uniti, his father-in-law, leader of Albanian's uprisings, in 1432 until 1435.
Vrana Conti, commander of Kruria Fortress in its first siege, in 1450.
Mimitsa Castrioti, hero's little sister, commander of Petrol Fortress near Tirana.
Tanushtopia, commander of Kruria Castle in its second and third siege, in 1466 and in 1467.
Lekdu Kajini is the leader of the Albanian army for 11 years in a row after Skanderbeg's death.
Pal Kuka, Skanderbeg's diplomat. Zahariya Gropa, Skanderbeg's diplomat.
Gjergj Leshi the warrior that killed Balaban Pasha in Kruria's second siege in 1466.
you